we begin this morning with the fast pace
of the impeachment inquiry into
president Trump following a
whistleblower complaint this week that
started a political firestorm mr. Trump
is facing allegations he pressure the
Ukrainian president to investigate
former Vice President Joe Biden a
potential 2020 rival and Biden's son
hunter in exchange for much-needed
military aid Democratic leaders in the
House issued a subpoena for State
Department documents and their
scheduling depositions with officials
named in that complaint one of those
officials kurt volker was mr. Trump's
special envoy to Ukraine he abruptly
resigned on Friday
Natalie Brent is at the White House
Natalie good morning good morning to you
Jeff and House Democrats leading this
investigation have indicated they want
to move quickly and begin depositions
including a volker as early as next week
the president meanwhile continues to
lash out over social media over the past
24 hours and he's made clear he plans to
make this a campaign issue at a White
House reception for Hispanic heritage
Friday night president Ron found a
supportive crowd a distraction from the
impeachment inquiry now ramping up on
the other end of Pennsylvania Avenue
while most lawmakers scrambled home for
a two-week recess three House Committee
subpoenaed Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo for documents on interactions
involving the president his lawyer Rudy
Giuliani and the Ukrainian government
centered to the investigation is a July
25th phone call between President Trump
and Ukraine's President Vladimir
zolensky we've already begun reaching
out to witnesses we're going to be
noticing depositions or interviews as
soon as next week we're going to hold
hearings as soon as we can the House
committees also want to depose five
State Department officials named in the
whistleblower complaint including
special envoy to Ukraine kurt volker
who's CBS confirmed resigned on Friday
one day after the complaint was publicly
released in part accusing the president
of pressuring Ukraine's president to
investigate former Vice President Joe
Biden and his son hunter at a campaign
event in Las Vegas Friday Biden fought
back after 70 straight polls have shown
me beating him it's not surprising that
I become the object of his attention Joe
Biden promised Ukraine a billion dollars
if they fired the prosecutor
investigating his son's company while
the Trump campaign and Republican
National Committee revealed a 10 million
dollar ad by targeting Biden and
Democratic lawmakers over what it calls
an impeachment charade
now a portion of the whistleblower
complaint focuses on White House
officials moving the transcript of that
Ukraine call to a separate computer
system reserved for highly classified
documents a senior administration
official confirms to CBS that it was
filed in that separate classified system
White House officials have cited leaks
as one reason for restricted access to
those types of documents Michelle all
right Natalie thank you